one of our silver values is just getting
done so we're 100 data driven we're
extremely driven by like result we work
fast and we measure everything and we
debrief and we continuously optimize but
you know we get done
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside fam Fusion VC Birthright Excel
J impact leap Google for startups and
hippo and in media partnership with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we
are with Dr Tamir Wolf the CEO and
co-founder of Theodore after graduating
medical school at the technion Tamir
served as a physician in the idf's
flotilla 13 the equivalent of SEAL Team
Six during his tenure in Naval special
ops Tamira was awarded the medal of
distinguished service for treatment of
wounded Under Fire transitioning to
civilian life Tamir found his passion
for the industry side of healthcare and
worked in various leadership positions
in startups and as a VC he co-founded
Theodore after witnessing the
unacceptable variability and disparity
in surgical care Tamir holds an MD and a
PhD from the Teflon and completed the
Executive MBA program at Harvard
Business School
really excited and honored to have you
here calling from Palo Alto with with
such an amazing company not just because
of the physiological breakthroughs and
the mission but because of I I
interviewed your co-founder maybe like
400 episodes ago and so I got to know a
little bit about what you're doing but
but your personal journey is uh is a
pretty phenomenal one on its own and and
while I know that you are extremely
humble and and that's why I also didn't
want to prepare you for this I I really
do want to hear a little bit about who
you are as a leader and who you are as a
CEO and not just not just the incredible
accomplishments which we've already
shared with the audience at this point
but but really what it's all about for
you and and what guides you through
these different Journeys in your life
these these different step functions
that you've gone through because you're
showcasing some pretty phenomenal levels
of Excellency and humility there's
things that you're doing so
share with me a little bit about your
own perspective you know who is Tamir
wolf
so I figure she wanted to to learn more
about like who I am as the leader as the
CEO you probably need to talk to my my
team uh I think they're more cohoid with
me to to talk about uh those things
honestly uh but let me you know I I will
share like hopefully so uh some thoughts
and insights that you know hopefully
your audience might might appreciate and
and benefit from
um you know I I think like uh throughout
my my uh my life and my career
everyone's always sold me Adelaide
Bloomer uh so I get the things later
in in Israel uh I did like ROTC so first
I did you know my poor adult life I went
through med school and then went to the
military on the and then you know spent
quite a bit of time in the Navy
and uh and honestly like you know for me
being in the Navy and I was like amazing
experience uh I learned that really you
know there I learned it's really all
about the team that you're with
and that you know you may have like very
lofty goals like when you're in the Army
you know this uh you know lofty goals
like protect your country Etc But
ultimately like what gets you through
the grind on a daily basis is you know
those left and right
um and so you ultimately do things for
that and with them and so I think that's
something that I faken with me uh while
I Journey you know even after uh leaving
the military it really is all about the
team
uh
and about
um being there for for one another
um and you know a lot of other aspects
that we're taking even today theater
like these concepts for example fnr rate
them into responsibility like brain
fellow talented individuals to the
company
that have that give it the right context
I'm of that type of
understanding awareness and just common
sense to just like move fast and get
things done
and in an environment where there's a
lot of transparency I think that helps
build each and every one of us so that
you can actually move very very quickly
uh depending again on one another and so
you know maybe that's just a little like
intro connecting my past with my present
wow so
still you know tell me a little bit
about your passion for you know medicine
for health for for making an impact
because this is something that's been a
Common Thread across a variety of things
that you've done well you know and also
the previous companies that you found in
your studies and your army service and
the the award you received what is it
about health and about helping others
that that does it for you so I think uh
like life's short and you need to make
impact uh in whatever you do but in
general I think you know we need to
leave like this will hold a little bit
better than you know the way than what
we got or received when when we arrive
you know honestly looking back at my
life I think that uh
a lot a lot of like my values and the
things that I really believe in account
for a lot like my grandmother
she's a holocaust Survivor she was a
holocaust Survivor she raised me my my
parents were worked a lot as as a kid uh
and uh she always wanted to be a doctor
but then like the Holocaust you know got
to her when she was 16 and she went to
Auschwitz so she never got you know to
achieve that and saw how like you know
subliminally
uh I I got like the urge to become a
physician
um and so went to med school with the
idea of you know being able to have
impact on people's lives uh and and
ultimately I think you know I did like
at some point in my career I think this
was after the white my time in the Navy
I did like about me on the little
calculation
you know thought all right like as a
physician or a surgeon which is where I
would have like added up uh I think
going because I need like immediate
gratification
um and so you know surgery is probably
where I would have landed
um like I I have this concept of let's
go back and leave a little calculation
like what is the number of lives that I
can actually touch well I likes that
and I realized that building a company
is probably a way to have like a much
broader impact even though like the
interaction I'll run out of line the
ability to to save an individual life is
like so precious
But ultimately I went through the route
and let's build something that really
need to really be impactful a little and
an impact billions of people around the
world
um and ultimately I lived at a theater
where our mission is really to save
lives by tackling variability into
sternian surgery but you can think about
it as like many different like ways
um I have to say that like just last
year well I had a personal reminder of
like hello just like saving Wildlife can
be
uh like I think it was uh like a month
or two after I raised my series A
and um I diagnosed myself with cancer
and so like most of last year I was
dealing with multiple surgeries and with
chemo and I got like really appreciate
you know about my surgeon I've been like
my caregiver really has an impact on me
so the on a one out of one
um but ultimately you know feeding back
into what we're doing at theater the
idea is you know I went to the person
who has the most experience in the world
around like my specific uh
procedure and you know archaeological
aspect I don't know I now need to take
his style Edge and capabilities and
disseminate them around the world
um so that no matter where you live the
so that like this aspect of like where
you live determines if you live isn't
something that uh you know Remains the
case uh and so you know this is like
sort of connecting you know the
individual to like the uh you know to
the communities that we live here uh but
so long going did answer hopefully I I I
I I responded to like saw things you
were interested in here
wow I don't even know how to continue to
interview from this point that's uh I
mean
so you're looking at the impact
that you're looking to have and uh
further from personal experience that
seemed unbelievable but if you're
looking at really the impact that you're
you're you you're seeking to have with
Theodore tell me let's let's dive a
little bit more into what you're doing
and and I want to constantly connect it
back also to the way this is a part of
your own personal mission statement for
impacting lives so how do you put
together you know Health literally
changing a person's life you know which
means you have to make a dramatic
difference in the way that they are
receiving something in their
experiencing something to scale of a
start of that Venture Capital backed
so yeah I started with it I'll come back
to it I think it's really about the team
especially if we're looking you know
whether it's in Palo although or in Tel
Aviv uh there's so much talent uh in
these like and in these like uh
Geographic Pockets you know people that
can do so many different things and I
think uh you know maybe one of the
things that I want to impress here is
that you know you can do so many
different things
um but no I think choose the one that
you know potentially as like leave us
then Pat and does and actually does good
so you know coming back to the this
aspect of uh of Team
um I've been blessed that together with
my co-founder we've been able to
assemble really an amazing uh group of
individuals that are like-minded uh and
are focused on our vision really
creating a world where our um where it
doesn't matter where you where you live
or wherever your surgeon train you know
you're getting like the best uh the best
type of treatment uh and and I think
that like that that really is at the
core of what we're doing at theater
um
uh because today like the the status quo
is that surgery like medicine is pretty
much in a practice uh you know
where where someone trained or the the
patient population they were uh familiar
with well really dictates how they are
going to practice surgery for the rest
of their lives which obviously has a lot
of impact on
on patients as well
um and so how do you identify best
practices how do you disseminate how do
you identify individuals who are not up
to par
um from a search called performance
capability and you level them up uh all
of this can can be done today uh could
be done very easily by leveraging
technology which is what we're bringing
to the table uh and and I think that uh
and it's more and more leading
institutions in the world around the
world embrace the ability of just
leveraging all the infrastructure that
we have today but like the power
specifically the power of data uh in in
the OR which is pretty much like the
left side of the way think of
non-transparency that's really how we
take it to the next level uh and so
again to summarize a great group will
get the visuals that are extremely
Mission driven which I think is
something that sets theater report for a
lot of other companies that you could
work at
around the world uh take that expertise
identify best practices and allow
disseminations in ways that are really
novel
um I think that on on our path uh really
will allow us to
um to again shatter that status quo
where you live determines if you live
um and I got a reason for theater being
a few years ago living in New York
I diagnosed my wife and my previous
password appendicitis and I took him to
two different hospital and the approach
achievement and treatment were very very
different
uh met and so you know in in one case my
with my boss uh is clearly evident that
you know decisions were wronged along
the way which led to uh
ultimately like near-death experience
and with my wife it was very different
it was 12 hours from the moment we set
foot in the emergency room until we were
back home
and so you know that's when I really
started to wonder what is going on here
like in this world and how can it be
back then it was like 2015 uh that in
2015 uh within you know a seven mile
distance in New York City you have a
very different approach and treatment
for like a similarly a similar condition
well so that takes us back the origins a
bit of theater
you were mentioning putting together a
remarkable group of people that are
like-minded on a joint mission
tell me a little bit about how how
you've seen that is an impactful part of
Theodore's Journey
so I think like throughout throughout my
personal life uh
whether it's in uh whether it's in the
show that uh
um or or afterwards
um
being the part of uh of like a type
knitting
um that always knows where they're
heading oh and why they're doing what
they're doing that has been important
um and you know as I mentioned like in
Palo Alto or the Bay Area or Tel Aviv
for that matter
there's so much opportunity for folks I
mean a developer can go and do ads or
you know any other type of uh uh company
it doesn't really matter unless
um they have it in their heart and minds
they want to do something that really is
impactful that it's going to change the
trajectory of an individual's life well
and that can come in many shapes or form
but you know at theater we really filter
for that type of persona or like
individuals that are you know extremely
accomplished audible can do anything
that they want to do and yet choose to
spend their time focusing on how to make
you know this place a better place and
how do I in fact into the jawline
and I think that has come in like
extremely uh extremely handy
um aldinu ascends uh like we are four
years old we're roughly
uh our first employee came on board
about November 12 2018. uh so almost
four years old uh very very soon uh and
we are almost 50 employees and in the in
the stand of those pouring years both
intellivated Palo Alto we only had one
individual that has opted to leave us uh
and that was like for personal reasons
not really related to what we were doing
with the company and so ultimately
I think that you know says a lot about
you know what we're doing and how we're
doing and the culture in the company and
our value system at Large
that's unbelievable 50 people only one
person opted to leave not necessarily
even for
for the traditional reasons but that
that's just that's just remarkable
exactly what what do you and what what
do you require yourself so you meant you
mentioned that first the the conviction
of the person that you are in front of
you know they it sounds like you you
know you require that they represent
Excellency that they represent the
ability to take any Challenge and a
problem and to adapt and to and to
perform extremely well but that's not
enough it's just a foundation what
really counts is is their intentionality
what they're here for their ability to
choose Theodore not decide on Theodore
in comparison to others but to really
choose this as a journey for themselves
right
and I think uh it it you know at theater
like we've got this concept of like
theater DNA so does this individual have
like a theater DNA and I think that
theater DNA embodies like multiple
values uh but first of all it's like
we're human first so we're doing deep
fat
um but it depends on the people who
create it
um and so we're humble we're kind if we
have empathy then we can successfully
tackle anything that comes our way uh
you know another is another one of our
uh silver values is just getting
done uh so we're 100 data driven we're
extremely driven by like result we
worked fast and we measure everything
and we debrief and we continuously
optimize but you know we get you done
well every voice counts and specifically
your voice counts isn't it like whether
it's a patient or a surgeon or a team
member
you know we we depend on individuals you
know challenging challenging themselves
continuously voicing their opinions uh
and also challenging each other in the
status quo why not so that's another one
of the values that I think we embody of
theater and and ultimately and I started
with this it's this concept of shared
understanding all along where only when
we all see like the big picture well
we're transparent then everyone has
context
um can we achieve economy and like that
truly makes a difference and helps us
move forward very very quickly
um and you know this like you know for
for early stage companies speed is of
the essence so I think that what we're
looking for
is individuals that you're right like
excellence in the specific domain is
like that's like only foundation but
even if you're like you know the
smartest and you know the whole stable
in like a specific area
that doesn't cut it unless you have that
type of DNA that embodies like the rest
of the volumes that I just mentioned
to me and such an incredible journey and
one that I uh I uh yeah I'm I'm with you
on so many of the different things that
you were saying and some different
things that you're so intentional about
and not just rationally as an
entrepreneur but it sounds like through
really you know real real lived
experiences both from far behind but
also recent and so I I really appreciate
you know the time the energy not just on
these 20 minutes but everything that
you're doing and it sounds like you've
built an amazing family around you and
uh and I can very much relate to this
concept the notion of you know
um human first sympathy first and and
creating a team that together can can
beat any Challenge and and and and if
what if one person wins everybody wins
that that sort of mentality and
obviously from the Navy and test neon
and the different things you've done I'm
sure that it's been a significant part
here and so to me I really want to thank
you for coming on I really appreciate
everything and stay safe and stay
healthy and best of luck with Theodore
well good thanks cycle it was lovely to
be here
[Music]